you've always been so hopeful since I've
met you you you always represent hope
and you do it publicly and you also do
it privately
and I know we both we both also have our
moments of feeling that the obstacles
for girls and women around the world are
hard
in the really hard moments where does
your Hope come from
I think there are a number of things
that give me hope
um
I I used to watch Bollywood films when I
was young and in in those films like
they're usually for three hours for me
that's fine but if you say to a person
from the UK that says too long but three
hours is fine and in those films there
would be a good life starting in the
beginning there would be a boy liking a
girl and things would be going well and
then the villain would come
and just ruin everything but then the
hero would go back and defeat the
villain and things would be fine again
and that was
happy ending so I always believed in
happy ending and that's how I used to
look at my own story that even if things
are harder whatever was happening in
swat Valley then how I went through the
incident I was hoping for a happy ending
in my story and I think that's something
that has always given me hope that
things will get better things will go
positive and if we just look back at
history how things have
gotten better like for example the the
rights of women to vote and suffrage
those things have improved there's we
see if we compare things we see things
have improved we see more equality not
not reached to the extent we want but
still we see progress and I think that
things give me hope that things will get
better but also my family and the people
who I am around who support me uh that
just gives me hope and I think it's just
pointless to be hopeless because there's
nothing that you can get all you do is
just harm yourself is just disappoint
yourself more and you just achieve
nothing
so it's good to be awful it's good to be
positive at least you enjoy your present
uh and at least you enjoy some moments
of your life if you are hopeless you
waste your present and you're kind of
also wasting your future
[Applause]
oh question uh
I just never thought I'd be asking you a
question
but I think um
how do you see
um
the role of mother not just mother but
as father as well because my father was
not just father to me but also mother
and I see my mother not just mother but
father and I think it's just the idea of
Parenthood that is important so how do
you see yourself as mother but also as
father to your children
well I've thought a lot about this
because I you know my my children don't
have a father anymore
um and I think you know as parents we
just want the best for our children
and sometimes I try to think what would
Dave say what would he do
and sometimes I have the answer and
sometimes I don't and then I just try to
do the best I can
I do think that we have to do a better
job
raising our boys and our girls to both
be leaders and both be givers from young
young ages we tell little boys not to
cry man up
we tell little girls not to lead you're
too bossy and so these messages that
give these stereotypical roles in these
homes which are really outdated in a lot
of the world and should be outdated in
the rest of the world continue and it's
really amazing they do these studies in
the United States by the age of 14. if a
girl sees her father doing chores
washing dishes doing laundry doing
housework with the mother
she has broader career Ambitions than
girls that don't so no matter how often
you say to your daughter you can do
anything dear
she needs to see equality and so I think
that means that when our fathers are
active fathers when our mothers show
leadership and our fathers show
leadership and our mothers are active
mothers that starts to break down the
stereotypes that I think are holding
back the world because they're keeping
men in power
okay
we would love to take some audience
questions now I know there are a lot of
people here who have who've gone through
hardship in some way and if you do have
a story that you want to share you can
go to optionb.org and we build community
around people exchanging experiences
we want to keep the questions focused
today on building resilience on
supporting women and girls and in the US
we always like to remind people that
questions end in a question mark
um here we don't need to do that because
in London even statements send in a
question mark
uh but if you have a question for Malala
or Cheryl or both we would be thrilled
to take it
Cheryl this is a question for you I am a
Avid Reader of lean in and it has
changed my mindset and wanted to ask you
first of all to say how sorry I am to
have heard the news and you seem to have
been I suppose in the last four years
I've seen a lot of videos that you've
you've been in and also in your recent
BBC interview talking about your life
now as a single woman can you tell us a
little bit more about how professionally
you've managed to deal with not having a
partner as a single lady because you
used to talk in lean in about how as a
strong woman and you had your partner
and before that your ex-husband and how
it was in a way a very important part of
your life to have that person how do you
deal with it now I'm so sorry to ask you
a difficult question but I'm interested
to know
it's an important question you know and
I wrote lean in I certainly wrote about
and thought about different forms of
family and talked about the poverty
single mothers were living in but I also
wrote an entire chapter called make your
partner a real partner
and what I realized is that that title
chapter had the same problem as the
father-daughter dance does at my
daughter's school that I cannot get rid
of
there are kids without fathers so do
they have to call it that
right why can't they call it the you
know daughter friend dance or something
so everyone could bring someone and
similarly did I have to call my chapter
make your partner a real partner which
has this assumption that everyone has
one and I apologize publicly for it I
did a post
a year ago on Mother's Day
and what I realized again is that there
are so many different forms of family
but particularly families struggling
losing a spouse pushes a lot of women
into really abject poverty all over the
world
some of the Customs for widows around
the world are truly horrific absolutely
horrific but even in the most developed
Nations losing a spouse pushes people
into poverty and as not having a spouse
and we just need to do better and that's
public policy corporate policy and the
way we support each other something I've
thought about a lot and I thank you for
asking me about
[Applause]
we're going upstairs
good evening and thank you for your
inspiring stories I have a question with
a question mark I promise
um
you received great advice that to remind
yourself of what could be worse
but when you've lived through something
directly or indirectly
how do you make sure you don't focus on
everything that could go wrong children
being alive
the family being together
and if you feel that anxiety how do you
make sure you don't share it with your
family and you manage that
question mark
you want to take that second one yeah
um
I think for me the most important thing
is to accept
who I am and to accept the present and
to
and I and as I said I always try to stay
positive and try to look at the the good
things in life what I have and after
that I when I realized that I had lost
Hearing in my left ear that I had my
facial now for the left side of my face
was cut down and the movement of my left
side of my face was affected and then
later on I did surgery and it improved
and uh that I realized that it can never
go perfect again and I realized that the
things I had lost and I think it just
reminded me of the things I had and the
things I should be thankful for for
having a vision to being able to hear to
being able to speak and to being able to
be to be thankful for what I have from
things that I have personally in my body
but also to have family to have friends
to be together with them to enjoy each
and every moment of my life so I try to
stay positive but then there are hard
times when you get nervous I'm not like
a completely a fake person that every
day is a happy day
um and hardships do come in life there
are moments when you hear things you
hear bad comments from people you hear
you have exam stress you have that
anxiety you are worried about your
speech your uh what you are going to say
tomorrow how things are going to happen
whether you are on the right path
whether you need to do something more in
life so we all go through these
difficulties these challenges in our
life but I think the best thing is to be
patient and to give yourself time don't
be in any hurry don't don't stress
yourself to give yourself time and
that's what I did I give myself time and
I said focus on your studies do the work
that you can right now in your school's
study time stay focused on on yourself
build up yourself learn and live a
normal life as a student as a girl and
so that's what I did and that's how I
made sure I recover in a very positive
and Safe Way
[Applause]
hi my question is for Cheryl about
teaching kids resilience I think
sometimes as a parent you have a desire
to protect your kids and shield them
from heartache but you also I think as a
parent have a responsibility to teach
them to be resilient so how do you find
that balance and
um yeah if you have any advice for that
we've studied this extensively I'm going
to let Adam answer this question we've
wrote a chapter about this in our book
uh there's there's a great book by uh
Julie lithgott Hames called how to raise
an adult which is all about this and it
says the first thing you have to do is
normalize struggle you cannot protect
your children from all struggle right
they will have challenges whether they
fail an exam or they you know don't make
the the football team or you know they
forget their lines in a school play and
I think that you have to show them that
that is okay right that's normal that
happens to you and that means letting
them see you struggle too the other
thing we found from the research on
raising resilient kids is kids have to
know that they matter and mattering is
just the belief that that other people
notice you care about you and rely on
you and I think as parents I know as a
parent I I know the first two pieces of
that they're really clear you know pay
attention to your kids right show that
you love them check but we forget the
kids also need to feel relied on and
dependent on that other people count on
them and that's part of what signals to
them look I have confidence in you right
I believe you have strength and so I
think one thing that we can all do those
of us who have kids is when You Face a
big challenge you go to your kids and
you ask them for advice what would you
do in this situation and it teaches them
that they're trusted to deal with it and
then it also lets them practice the
coping skills that they're going to need
once they do face hardship
foreign
this is for Cheryl
um what has been one of your biggest
challenges being see our Facebook
what was the question I think we applaud
for the question first of all
Adam can you hear it
for those who couldn't hear the question
was uh Cheryl what's been one of your
biggest challenges as CEO of Facebook
asking a question how old are you
how old are you I'm 10. yay
wow
well I think we all look forward to what
you're gonna do
um the challenges have changed
I think the first and most important
challenge when I showed up is I'm trying
to figure out how to scale the company
and how to have a business model so when
I first showed up at Facebook
we were very good at connecting people
and helping them share but we weren't so
good at making the money that would pay
to connect people and help them share
and it turns out that for a business
that's an unsustainable place to be
but we do that very well now often led
by great women Nicola Mendelson's here
Nicholas stand up Nichola runs emea for
Facebook and she is incredible
and so one of the ways I met that
challenge is I just found fantastic
people around the world to hire
and gave them the opportunity to do what
they do
if we have any other girls in the
audience who want to demonstrate their
executive leadership skills now would be
now's your time we'll take anyone any of
those questions
hi Festival thank you so much for coming
over to England and speaking
um my question is a bit explicit but
um in the current global social climate
where the self-styled leader of the Free
World the president of the United States
Advocates grabbing women by the
how can we look at children in the eyes
and say that sexual and psychological
violence against women isn't legitimized
[Music]
there's no place for violence against
women and there's there's no place of
any kind unfortunately
violence against boys girls men women
has been part of every culture it
remains part of every culture there is
against both genders there is more
against women
and it is uh completely unacceptable and
we know that
and we know that as we think about how
we raise our sons how we raise our
daughters and how we make sure there's
no tolerance for
that behavior you know of any kind I
think people worry about what's
happening to girls on college campuses
they should be worried about that people
worry about what happens to kids
in families when they're on the street
and silence is the enemy of all of this
for for many many literally hundreds of
years this stuff always happened and
wasn't talked about
and we need to shine a bright Spotlight
on it and make sure we don't teach it
and we don't tolerate it always
you know just add one thing to that and
I think
I have always been really worried and
really careful about this is that we
should not harm anyone whether that is
harming them physically or harming them
mentally we should not harm anyone and I
think that's the biggest mistake or the
the wrong thing or the wrong deed or the
sin or anything we call it that is ever
we can do is harm another person is harm
their feelings is hurt them is and I
think that's something we should always
avoid in our life if we want to be
responsible people if you want to be
good people that you need to take care
of other people and I and I think it's
our social responsibility it is it is
our responsibility as individuals as
well that we make sure that we do not
cause any pain any harm in in anyone's
life so make sure that before you
comment before you say anything you're
taking care of people you are thinking
about their feelings and their emotions
and uh just consider those people as
yourself be in their position and they
think about them how how you would feel
if you were instead of them so it's
important that we care for others that
we count them as equal to ourselves and
that we know that if someone had harmed
us how we would have felt so let's avoid
any harm any pain for others and and
know that it's your responsibility not
to harm because sometimes we just I
don't care and I think it's important
um and like it's so shocking that people
on leadership skills you want them to be
Role Models you want them to be running
countries if you hear these hateful
comments if you hear these uh comments
that are gender biased that are
um Sexes this is this is really really
harmful for society you're telling
people it's okay to be sexist it's okay
to be racist it's okay to harm people
whether that's through your bad comment
or whether that's physically that you
are telling the people it's okay but
it's not okay we have to be careful we
have to be responsible and we have to
make sure that we realize that we are
living in a civilized society where
human beings and we have this sense of
of being nice to each other and we have
this sense that we should not harm
others
[Applause]
we're gonna go over here next I just
want to add quickly I think this is one
of the reasons we need more women
leaders the data are very clear across
countries that when we have women in
politics and Leadership roles we
actually see more piece and I think it's
a it's a travesty that I've done this
for years with students have asked them
to name who are the leaders that you
admire most who are your role models
over a thousand answers only two women
have been named and those two women are
actually Malala and Cheryl
but
um but but that's a problem it's a huge
I mean that's a huge problem it's a huge
problem and I think that you know we
have lots of women who name male leaders
as role models we need to be able to say
look as a man these are two of my role
models and they are both women and
that's something we should all look up
to